hi everyone I'm Brian inar senior
creative director Insomniac games and
I'm Marvel Spider-Man 2 and I'm here to
answer your questions on the internet
this is video game
[Music]
support first question Ben edel asks how
did you guys come up with the web
shooting sound first off we hire a
really awesome audio team they actually
told me that what they do is they have
silly string plastic wrap shrink wrap
and they even make those flip sounds
like with their voices it's all
integrated into making our awesome web
sounds as a cre director I see overall
see everything on the project but I do
not offer my own sound effects because
nobody wants that gamer paa asks honest
question do game directors focus on the
overall Creative Vision of a game or do
they have some type of programming
coding skills so you actually don't need
to have programmer or coding skills
there's a lot of different ways to
become a creative director or a game
director I actually started out as a
journalist writing about video games and
eventually I said hey I'd love to go
work at a studio and I actually started
working on ziac roughly 15 years ago and
I started out in the community team
answering emails talking to our fans a
couple years later became a producer and
then one day back in 2014 walked into
the office of Ted price our president
CEO he asked me what do I think about
working on the Marvel game yes please
and I said I don't want to be the
producer I want to be the creative
director if you have a passion willing
to work hard and you work well with
others you can do anything you want at
Ben N64 asks the game Spider-Man 2 Venom
is the best Venom design changed my mind
Ben not going to change your mind I
completely agreee with you we want to
take all of the elements that players in
fans love about Venom whether it's his
size the symbol his teeth his mouth his
eyes the transformation the power so we
want to kind of be respectful of the the
DNA of the character but also not be
afraid to mix things up and you take
that all into
account get 19 inches of Venom all 19
this is actually the part of the
collector's edition and that features
both of our Spider-Man fighting their
toughest challenge yet in the form of
venom them pretty badass Matthew guz
asks what's your game design philosophy
in tweet form you want to deliver the
fantasy while making a world and
characters that you absolutely love and
want to spend time with silent wraith 87
asks how do you decide which suits go in
the game is it personal preference or do
you think about abilities and which
suits would match up well with them and
are you free to pick or do Marvel have a
say wow where do I begin we know there
are suits that everybody wants we talk
to Marvel we talk to our Sony producers
we get artists to create brand new suits
had never been made before suits are
unlocked via basically having hitting a
certain Hero level and then having the
right resources to craft it so that's
how you do and then because we have two
Heroes we have like over 65 suits and
now we want to go even bigger with that
so now the majority of Suits have what
we call suit style so there's usually
four different suit Styles you can
unlock for that suit which means we have
like over 200 different suits in the
game which is crazy but at the same time
we're hope we hope we got everything
every we wanted it's like Christmas and
it's the all the present are under the
the tree and you're like I hope I got
them everything they wanted Clay 864
asks but is there going to be a
Spider-Man 5 console like we got with
the PS4 from the first game damn
straight there's going to be got this
sweet controller Symbio takeover but the
real cool stuff is this sweet sweet
sweet console I don't even have one yet
as we sit here this idea of the symbiot
and takeover not only thematically works
for the console but it ties very heavily
to what we're doing in the game so it's
awesome designs super happy that um
PlayStation wanted to do it at Dees
pumpkins with a z asks is New York City
inspiring 2 built a scale it is not our
idea is we want to create a New York
City that kind of you have in your head
whether you've been there you seen in
the movies there's tons of recognizable
elements whether it's certain
neighborhoods certain buildings and then
of course this is Marvel's New York so
we want to have things like Avengers
Tower the wakon embassy and what's been
really awesome on Spider-Man 2 is that
we've nearly doubled the size of the
city with the addition of Brooklyn and
Queens so now you see things like Cony
Island you see where Miles goes a school
at Brooklyn Vision Academy and even Pete
now living at Aunt May old house and now
with things like the web Wings you can
cross things like the East River and our
bridges much easier than you couldn't
pass because in the last games you
couldn't even do that at the anime G
asks the web Swinging with certain
aspects added are so refreshing I'm kind
of interested to see how they can make
Spider-Man 2 as cool as Miles Morales as
web swinging how we make exploring the
world and getting around the world
better the web Wings we knew really
early on actually we actually prototyped
it really early in Spider-Man one but we
were like ah we don't know it's a cool
idea but we just don't really have the
time for it right now so we knew by the
time Spider-Man 2 was rolling around was
like something we really wanted to do so
that's a big element it really does
change like you know so many times
playing Spider-Man 1 you'll be above the
the buildings you're like well I want to
keep going and now you can just press
triangle and boom pop those web wings
and keep gliding just keeping that
momentum when you don't have a web line
available but I think we've added other
things like being able to turn a corner
really really fast what people have
asked for a long time is yes you can do
the loop to Loop now in our game you can
unlock that skill so adding all new
animations adding more swing animations
we know we've heard you you guys like
swing animations we get it we've added
more at FK 729 asks do you think that
Spider-Man 2 is story-wise combat wise
better than the 2018 Spider-Man game God
I hope so cuz we've been working really
hard to deliver that it's not just a
story of Peter it's not just a story of
miles it's a story of both Peter and
miles and they're not only their journey
together but individually so
One mission may just be as Pete One
mission may just be as miles some
missions actually been playing as both
of them are switching back and forth so
we kind of control it while in the open
world we give you a lot more Choice and
then basically what we've done is
created content that specific for Peter
specific for miles and the combat front
we've just been adding a ton of stuff
whether it's you know new powers for
miles and the evolved Venom to obviously
our symbiote abilities with
Pete hell yeah this game is better than
Spider-Man one 09 Missy G asks how do
you write a compelling story that works
for an open world game where the player
could experience it out of order or even
circumvent Parts entirely part of an
open world thing that people love is
having that freedom right when you're
making something like Spider-Man we
understand you know when it comes to
Marvel everything starts with our story
what are they going through not only in
The Mask but out the mask it's a
balancing act we have an amazing team of
writers um that work on this for years
we start really really broad give me the
paragraph of what the story is about and
then we go into a story treatment the
story treatment can go half a page to
one page to five pages to 20 pages okay
here's what act one act two act three is
about and then we go into okay within
act one there's probably five six seven
missions and we start to build out a
macro which shows kind of how it's going
to flow together and then from there
when we have kind of Buy in from the
team and everybody on what the story
treatment is we start to write scripts
lazy Justin asks how does Insomniac
manage to put out such high quality
games like every 2 years like what is
their secret there is no perfect answer
because no development is perfect it's
not going to go perfect but what we
always try to do is kind of
self-evaluate ourselves what can we
learn from our previous production that
we can apply to the next game back in
the day you would release a game and
you'd kind of be done with it now you
know even for a single player game
you're looking at player feedback maybe
there's something that you know is
tripping people up that we can update
the game really quickly obviously with a
multiplayer game they're continually
updating they're rebalancing they're
putting out new content the industry is
evolved development is still going even
when it's out at Zack Ruden asks how
exactly does one go about designing a
game to optimize the serious horsepower
of the PS5 so first off we're very
fortunate to have Mark cery the
architect of the PlayStation 5 be one of
our producers I think it's this
combination of learning about what the
console can do what can the console do
that maybe we couldn't do before what
could we do in previous games now we can
do better I think when you look at
Marvel Spider-Man 2 in comparison to our
previous games there are a multitude of
things that we couldn't do before we
could not swing as swing as fast as we
do now the world wouldn't have loaded
the way it needs to load as you're
swinging if we didn't have that our hero
switching that we do in the open world
would never be as fast as it is I think
our set pieces we'd have to do a lot
more smoke in mirrors than we actually
are doing we're taking our favorite
comic panels our favorite movie moments
and going hey we're going to do that in
a video game and put you in control
Knight Persian asks how does Insomniac
get such detailed textures damn their
engine is amazing it is amazing our
teams work really closely with our
engine team one of the benefits of
having our own engine is that there's so
much collaboration going on between our
artists our lighter our effects team
everything to come together because you
can have an awesome texture but if it
doesn't have great lighting it's not
going to look as good as you want at
moonlink games asks what do you think
has been the most significant
advancement in gaming recently I would
say the amount accessibility that all
developers across the world are adding
to their games whether making swinging
more accessible combat anything we can
do to get more players playing our games
is a huge win and it's something we're
always continue to do from here on out
at post mesmeric asks I often wonder how
Bean developers determine what should be
considered the default settings in their
games I think it starts off with who you
making your game for our goal first off
is we want to make it accessible and
playable by as many people as possible
so that's whether it's our how difficult
the enemies are defeat to our traversal
controls our combat controls but at the
same time we understand that there are
also hardcore fans who want like really
tough challenge so we offer difficulty
modes but what we usually do is we're
testing our game with people who come
into our usability labs and check it out
and sometimes they say this is way too
easy sometimes they say it's way too
hard and then we kind of go back and
forth and just try to find that sweet
spot at Indie Wolverine asks was there a
single game that impacted you so much
that you can confidently say it led to
you having a career in the video
industry maybe not one game but it was
one console was the original Nintendo
the 8bit Nintendo I think you know I
remember that Christmas I got my first
Nintendo and playing Zelda and Metroid I
remember like when I lost the code to
Metroid where I was and cried my eyes
out even realizing the game wasn't as
long as I thought it was when I was a
kid from when I was a little kid all the
way to now I still use it to kind of
Escape for a little bit and I mean I
know it's probably cliche to say but I
can't believe I a pay to do this at Von
Romero asks how often do you alter game
mechanics to fit the story or perhaps
how do you use game mechanics to benefit
a story Spider-Man 2 a big element of
the story is the Symbio they talked
about forever when are we having the
Symbio story well guess what it's coming
but it's not just part of our story Pete
has that black suit but it's not just a
new suit you know he has all these left
of symbiote abilities that we wanted to
show off how different it makes Pete's
fighting style you know so we think of
our Spider-Man as these acrobatic
improvisers with the Symbiote it was
really important for us to show off not
only the power of this substance but
also its transformational nature so
people love the Symbio 126 gaming just
curious if there's any new variations to
random crimes I remember an Ultimate
Spider-Man which is a great game
sometimes smaller villains like shocker
and Boomerang which spawn as as an event
do you guys have anything like that in
this game we definitely have done more
to uh spice up our random crimes with
more surprises we also have a bunch of
things in the open world that you can do
where you can discover some new story
lines um that aren't part of the main
story that are optional but I can
promise you if you like villains you
will be rewarded J main 518 asks will
Spider-Man 2 have multiple graphic and
performance mode options like the
remaster in the Miles Morales games it
sure will so we'll offer Fidelity mode
which runs at 30 frames a second and
runs in 4k we'll have performance mode
which goes around to 60 but takes a
little a little bit we reduce the
resolution a little bit and then for
people have 120 HZ TVs we actually have
an option where you can run at 40 HZ and
kind of get the best of both worlds but
no matter what mode you're running in we
will have R Trace Reflections so when
you want to see how awesome like you go
up to a window and you want to see your
Spider-Man suit not just on the
character but in the reflections of the
windows it's going to look white
hot awesome two fool asks why are video
games important sometimes real life is
not the greatest thing in the world and
sometimes we just need to find a way to
take a break from it reset whether we
want to you know be link be Mario be
Spider-Man sometimes we need that time
to ourselves to kind of Escape for a
little bit it's okay to you know take a
break from real life cuz sometimes as
great as real life can be it can be
stressful it can be hard it can be tough
but having those moments to kind of take
a break and reset has been really great
and I hope that we we can do that with
the games that we make thank you for all
the questions today they were in the
words of Marvel
[Music]
amazing